-Justin and I about to go
head-to-head or face-to-face
in a game of Facebreakers.
Now, we're going to take turns
chipping golf balls
at that wall of glass
with our faces on it.
That is my face.
That is Justin's face.
When we hear this sound...
[ Air horn blows ]
...that means it's
the speed round and we'll hit as
many balls as we possibly can.
The first person to break all of
their opponent's faces wins.
And we're upping the stakes
a bit tonight.
FedEx will be donating
$1 million
to St. Jude's
Children's Research Hospital
in the winner's name!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
How cool is that?!
-Awesome.
-It's my first
high-stakes golf game.
-Yeah.
-Justin, you're my guest.
You're up first.
Go on, try to break my face.
-What club we got here?
We got a little 8-iron?
♪♪♪♪
Got some tunes. I like it.
This is my kind of golfing
right here.
-I mean, come on.
-How hard do I need to
hit this thing?
Oh! Oh! Fore!
[ Laughter ]
-It's -- It's Facebreakers!
-I thought I was supposed to
actually try to break your face.
-Good Lord. Oh, my gosh,
you literally almost broke
my actual something.
All right.
-I feel like I should
cover up over here.
-Here we go.
[ Laughter ]
Ooh! From behind,
that would have been awesome.
Yeah, all right.
All right, you're up, buddy.
-Well, you got me all nervous
after that last one.
-Got me nervous?
Please.
You're shaking right now, dude.
-Oh!
-What's your problem, dude?
Watch.
Let me show you how it's done.
It's so easy, Justin.
Go like this. Watch.
[ Air horn blows ]
-Rapid fire?
-Wait. All right, rapid fire.
Here you go.
[ Air horn blows ]
Here's the horn. Go for it!
-Go, Jimmy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-Oh, look out! Fore!
Fore!
Oh, my God. [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I win!
♪♪♪♪
-The champ!
The champion right there!
-I'm good at this game.
-That means FedEx
will be donating $1 million
to St. Jude's
Children's Research Hospital
in Justin Thomas's name.
Justin Thomas, everybody!
Form was awful.
Check him out in the FedEx cup
playoffs starting August 23rd.
We'll be right back with
stand-up from Dusty Slay!
Stick around.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪